[Music]
copan ruinas is one of the most
mysterious and spectacular cities of the
Maya civilization at its height between
250 to 900 AD approximately 27,000 mile
IFFT here thereafter the civilization
mysteriously crumble and the copan
ruinas were left forgotten the ruins
discovered by Spaniard Diego Garcia del
palacio in the 16th century hid the
additional layers of buildings below
most notably the rasa-lila temple a
perfectly preserved temple inside
structure 16 discovered by
archaeologists in 1989
overall some 3450 structures have been
found within 27 square kilometers of the
principle group of ruins
coupons most famous monument is the
hieroglyphic stairway
[Music]
the flight of 63 steps bears a history
inscribed with more than 1,800 glyphs
but the entire story of the Maya is
still shrouded in mystery as some of the
stairway is eroded or jumbled some
archaeologists now believe the collapse
of copán was the result of a population
boom coupled with agriculture that could
not support the growth
[Music]